all right good morning everyone
welcome to the workshop on kovat 19 I
know a novel coronavirus genomics
workshop in this workshop will speak
about genomics data analysis and try to
understand how analysis tools can help
detect viral genomes in next-generation
sequencing data here we're gonna learn
how to distinguish between viral strains
identify specific functionally
significant changes in viral genomes and
we'll be discussing biology from a data
perspective let's start with the name
itself kovat 19 this name stands for
coronavirus disease and 19 is for the
year that this epidemic started which
was 2019 in this workshop we will try to
touch on these factors the corona virus
itself the disease and how it is a
result of viral transmission from animal
reservoirs as well as the entry into the
human cell we will be discussing the
collected data that we have from 2019
and the first three months of 2020 we
will speak about all of these from the
perspective of violin from attics which
allows us to study biology or in this
case virology as a data science together
with our collaborators we've been
building a growing online community of
bioinformaticians and training ranging
from high school students to faculty and
researchers and top universities around
the world our team offers big data
analysis tools and a quality learning
resource such as courses projects and
tutorials we have programs that are
designed around various topics
which discuss bioinformatics approaches
for processing analysis integration and
the interpretation of multi onyx data
from oncology neuroscience agro biology
as well as infectious diseases I
encourage you all to sign up for our
free courses as well as the ones that
are on our online portals and start
learning or teaching bioinformatics it
is one of the best ways that we can
explore the world around us at the
molecular level and there's going to be
zero equipment or lab costs associated
last Friday we met to review the basic
concepts that we needed to find
understand and start thinking about
publicly available datasets as well as
the tools for their analysis and I hope
that you enjoyed that session if anyone
wants a recording of that first webinar
please let us know this week we're going
to be holding two additional sessions
that we're going to be making available
to the public and these sessions will
continue to speak about sequence
analysis and we'll go deeper into the
world of coronaviruses looks like we
still have people still trying to join
with their video and sound I'll do my
best to kind of try to moderate that
I'll have to admit I have attention
deficit disorder so I may have to remove
you from the room if you distract me too
much
so anyways today we're going to be
continuing to speak about variations and
sequences that we can find by analyzing
data in our next session which is going
to be on Friday March 27th
we'll start exploring the way the
sequence changes are affecting protein
structure and function sequences of full
genomes individual reads from samples or
specific amplified regions can be used
to study natural variation diversity
changes over time and find changes in
RNA or DNA that can be linked to various
diseases can also be looked for things
that are involved in other types of
traits or phenotypic attributes such
links can be direct such as the change
in structure as a result of the
nonsynonymous mutation and these are
changes that occur at the protein
surface or other type of chemical
property or it can be indirect for
example silent changes or insertions
that change the way a process that has
many steps is modified slightly to
produce more significant changes today
we will speak about these kinds of
changes and methods of analysis that we
can use to find changes in sequences and
then annotate them as well as link them
with phenotypic data in today's session
will speak about topics from our full
program that's dedicated to
bioinformatics of infectious diseases
where we'll analyze data from public
domain sources and learn to interpret
the analysis results to learn about
various aspects of viral infections the
full protists excuse me the full program
will start on May 4th 2020 be sure to
check it out by going to the link that
I'll be posting in the chat
in today's session we're gonna be
speaking about the novel SARS
coronavirus and explore its origin as a
ZOA notic disease
as au ania disease is a disease that
comes from animals to humans in a
process called spillover we will learn
about the process of endocytosis by
which the virus enters the human cell to
replicate and then hijack the cellular
machinery for its protein production and
replication
we'll also be learning about several
data analysis approaches for genomic
data including detection of io genomes
and NGS data the identification of
viable strains and haplotypes finding
mutations that characterized by
Australians and then interpreting it
significant finally in order to apply
various methods of analysis we'll need a
lot of data so we'll be exploring
datasets that are related to current and
previous strains of coronaviruses such
as SARS MERS and the alpha and beta
coronaviruses Coronas in humans animals
and in various geo geographical
locations tend to be different and so
we're going to be talking about host
metagenomic samples as well as host
response data that can help us to detect
presence of viral strains discover new
strains or to understand the function of
various viral proteins this brief
session will only be an introduction
because the range of topics is broad and
comprehensive if you understand
bioinformatics and you're interested in
this area of bioinformatics
please make sure to sign up for the full
program where the same topics will be
explored in depth and then applied to
the study of several recent viral
pandemics such as Ebola flu an entire oh
very sorry enterovirus d68 additionally
we'll talk about infection
such as tuberculosis that are bacterial
origin to start speaking about these
topics let's first review the basic
terminology that help us to study virus
from a bioinformatics perspective this
is also a data perspective
bioinformaticians help extract
biologically meaningful information from
data that's often complex and it
requires many analysis steps to explore
patterns develop questions that can be
asked from our data and then ask
questions using analytical methods and
then the final step of that is to find
answers that can be validated so in this
workshop we're primarily going to be
speaking about genomic data and how it
can help us to study a virus which is
namely the pathogen behind kovat 19 this
is a disease that's caused by a
single-stranded RNA virus that's called
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus - because it belongs to the
corona virus family it's called a corona
because it has a crown like appearance
that's formed by its spike surface
proteins other corona viruses are
capable causing illness ranging from the
common cold to more severe diseases such
as MERS
this is also the seventh known corona
virus to infect people after a couple of
strains that I'm going to read out for
you which would be 22
sorry 229 e NL 6300 C 43 H ku1 Mars Cove
and then the original SARS kovat
analyzing the genomic data from publicly
accessible repositories allows us to
learn about the origin structure and
function and how this pathogen is
different from his family members the
common human corona virus usually causes
a mild to moderate upper respiratory
tract illness such as the common cold
most people get infected with one or
more of these viruses at some point
so there's a couple of human
coronaviruses that we have to talk about
remember earlier I said that there was
the 2229 e which is alpha coronavirus
there's also several beta corona viruses
such as OC 43 and then HKU one there's
also MERS SARS Cove SARS Cove 2 and then
that's the novel coronavirus that causes
corona virus disease and it's also
called coded 19 people around the world
commonly get infected with human
coronaviruses such as alpha and beta
corona viruses and so these are the most
common types that we'll be talking about
so just as a recitation the alpha and
beta corona viruses are gonna be 229 e
NL 63 OC 43 and HK u1 sometimes corona
viruses infect animals and they can
evolve and make people sick as well as
become a new human corona virus so three
recent examples of this are going to be
the 219 n cove SARS cove and then marys
cove so looking back through this these
are the different types of corona
viruses that we have so as we can see
there are delta gamma beta alphas and
then our human Tsarskoe bit 2 is a beta
corona virus before 2002 it was thought
that corona viruses cause only
self-limiting and mild infections of the
respiratory tract in human beings
two of the corona viruses that are
considered during this time were beta
corona viruses and the other two were
alpha these corona viruses were endemic
which means that are spread in certain
geographic areas and caused about
fifteen to thirty percent of the
infections of the respiratory tract each
year in the areas that they're endemic
to the SARS outbreak that happened in
china during 2002
2003 was caused by SARS coronavirus
which was a beta corona virus at the
time this outbreak was amongst the most
severe illnesses that had occurred due
to a corona virus and more than 8,000
people had the illness during this
epidemic researchers obtained viruses
that were closely related to the SARS
coronavirus from various exotic animals
such as raccoon dogs and the Himalayan
palm Cabot's but it's generally accepted
the SARS coronavirus was first found in
bats this this virus is ZOA notic
because it's spread between humans and
animals and the SARS coronavirus
outbreak is controlled in the year 2003
and since 2004 there haven't been any
known surahs cases reported anywhere in
the world after that a new human
coronaviruses in 2012 in the Middle East
and this was called MERS which is
another type of beta corona virus it's
caused in succession of highly
pathogenic infections of the respiratory
tract and this is endemic in the Middle
East during the initial stages of the
outbreak the illness was severe in many
cases but the outbreak didn't accelerate
until 2013 with only a few cases
occurring before that detailed
investigations found that MERS
coronavirus was passed from camels to
human beings and that SARS coronavirus
pass from Cubitt cats to human beings
both camels and cats were acting as an
immediate host and transmitted the
corona virus to humans of bats it's
important to ask questions that can be
answered with data typically this data
has to be analyzed and separated from
signal and noise and then we'll be able
to find patterns that are relevant to
the question that's being asked some of
this data is simple for example metadata
such as who collected the sample or
which type of location it was taken in
or the date there's not a lot of detail
and such data and it's prone to
misinterpretation as well as inaccuracy
however genomic data is very detailed
and accurate most of the time it can
offer deep in
sites into precise answers if the
questions are asked correctly once we do
that we can discuss how these patterns
and data can be interpreted and this
process is called extracting meaning
from data and it's the core of
bioinformatics and as we go through the
session start thinking about a question
that you want to ask to start let's take
one of these questions such as where did
this novel coronavirus come from or
maybe which animal location or how did
it start infecting humans and how do we
you know to answer this question we have
to find data patterns and they're
available genomes of coronaviruses that
can help us to answer this question ncbi
has a submission of this novel
coronavirus genome with metadata
included here it was submitted as
January 5th 2020 from China and the
collection date was December 2019 I'll
post a link in the chat to where you can
find this data on your own whenever you
get a chance so here we can go onto the
website and find some novel data about
our sequence to do so we can navigate
NCBI virus database and browse the
publicly available data you can simply
search NCBI virus or go to the link that
I'll post or that and let me see if I
can get that up for you
so as you get here one question you
might be asking is which virus tax ID
should we pick and the answer to that is
you would like to pick severe acute
respiratory syndrome related coronavirus
which has a tax ID of six nine four zero
zero nine so it's going to be the
penultimate one right here in the bottom
we can pause now and see if anyone has
any questions about getting to the
website and then I'm gonna try to push
through some of these slides and save
some questions for the end so that way
we can get through the material
so just to reset these steps we're gonna
go to this link and then we're gonna
look for severe acute respiratory
syndrome related coronavirus which has a
tax ID of six ninety four zero zero nine
you
and so we've gotten this far here and
then we can see that there are going to
be several strains so as you can see you
find over 1,500 sequences that are
available for us to study compare and
interrogate so the question we must ask
about the specific sequences that we
would like to select for our comparison
are when we do so we have to revisit an
important topic that we started speaking
about last time what is the question
that we're trying to ask recall that
last time we started following an
example found in research publications
where six sequences were compared there
were three from bats one from Pangolin
and two from human hosts let's try to
find a similar sequence in this database
we can select all of the 139 sequences
by selecting the hugh that checkbox at
the top of the list we have one question
which would be our reference genome so
what would the reference genome be if
you were selecting for SARS would it
possibly be humans
as I was saying then we can build a
phylogenetic tree that shows
relationships between these sequences in
a cladogram which is a tree like
dendrogram a phylogenetic tree shows
relationships between present-day
species based on both common ancestors
and time it has nodes branches clades
that depict the evolutionary distance
between taxa that we have sequences for
this tree can be horizontal radial or
circular and as we see in our tree we
have too many branches and nodes to
understand the relationships between
these sequences so what we would need to
do is go back and then reduce the number
of genomes and then run this analysis
again this time let's select a few
samples from a few years ago and then
compare them with current samples from
bats and humans so bats are mammals of
the order chiroptera and then there's a
family of bats commonly known as
horseshoe bats in addition to single
living genius the Rhino lapis is one
extinct genus there's also pear
lien-tsai Terrace which has also been
recognized horseshoe bats are closely
related to another type of bat called
hip hippo saudara
which are sometimes they've been
included in with Rhino lop today we can
add a few samples from 2005 to 2006 and
a few from 2018 and several from 2020 as
a result we have seven different genome
sequences from USA and China from bats
and humans and let's see what kind of
tree we can get now your tree should
look something like this
and as you notice the information this
tree gives us is limited because we add
year and host data from the previous
table please take a couple of minutes to
review the accession numbers and find
what here in species the samples are
from
so what do you think this tree shows
what type of information species
location and year can help us interpret
this phylogenetic tree well it says
China and USA
so let me add this information on the
slide so that we can quickly see the
answer so here we have the year of
collection so good job mr safe and yes
would you see that USA is clustered
together here now let's align these
sequences and see how alignment works so
you can click on the align box there and
it will align your sequences multiple
sequence alignment or MSA for short is
generally the alignment of three or more
biological sequences we can be pro which
can be protein or nucleic acid of
similar length from the output homology
can be inferred and the evolutionary
relationships between the sequences can
be studied by contrast there's pairwise
sequence alignment tools which are used
to identify regions of similarity that
may indicate functional structural
structural or evolutionary relationships
between two biological sequences some of
the commonly used tools for MSA are
called clustal Omega K line ma FFT
muscle and these are going to be
described as follows clustal Omega is an
MSA tool that uses seated guide trees
and hm-hmm profile techniques to
generate alignments this is suitable for
medium or large alignments Kaline is a
very fast MSA tool that concentrates on
local regions it's suitable for larger
alignments mapped is a tool that uses
fast Fourier transforms which is
suitable for medium large alignments and
the muscle is accurate
especially good with proteins this one's
also suitable for multiple or medium
alignments we have a couple of other
entries from our participants we have
prank and Eugene and there are many
different types of alignment tools so
here you'd want to select tools and then
coloring there's a frequency based
difference how many times a change in
sequence is found the more changes the
more read that we'll see the key is to
know what they're good for some for
short and some are for long sequences
also in here you need to select show
differences and this method highlights
differences from the master sequence
let's take a look at the result we want
to see that might be more significant of
these changes between our genomes if we
expand the genomes let me have an
annotation for we'll start seeing that
the genome is not just a string of
letters these regions code for proteins
that the virus will produce you will see
the gene name in some cases a name of
the encoding protein so some more
questions that we can ask are which gene
has a lot of differences between genomic
sequences
so I think the answer depends on what we
call difference our week are we talking
about substitutions deletions or
insertions and how do we quantify such
differences another question Who am I
ask is what are other major differences
that you observe in these different
genomes this might be this summer more
annotated than others and some have
visible gaps in their genomes compared
to the others let's talk a little bit
about the coronavirus genome itself so
what is the coronavirus genome in code
we can explore the sequence at the
nucleotide level to understand how the
virus genome was organized and then we
can find out the sequence variations we
observe so speaking a little bit more
about the genome here we have corona
viruses that are enveloped
positive-sense RNA viruses and they're
characterized by club-like
spike proteins that are projected from
their surface they have a unusually
large RNA genome as well as a unique
replication strategy these contain a non
segmented positive-sense RNA genome
that's around 30 kilo bases long and
this genome contains a 5 prime cap
structure along with a 3 prime poly a
tail this allows us to act as its mRNA
for translation of the replicates poly
proteins the replication gene encoding
the non structural proteins occupies two
thirds of the genome which is about 20
kilo bases as opposed to the structural
and accessory proteins which make up
only about 10 kilo bases of the viral
genome at the 5 prime end of the genome
there's a leader sequence and an
untranslated region that's called aut R
and this contains multiple stem loop
structures that are required for RNA
replication and transcription
additionally at the beginning of each
structural or accessory gene there are
transcriptional regulatory sequences the
required fridge
this three prime untranslated region
also contains RNA structures that are
required for replication and the
synthesis of viral RNA the organization
of these corona virus genomes feature is
a five prime leader untranslated
replicase S which is the spike protein
II which is for the envelope M for the
membrane n stands for nucleo capsid and
then remember that there's the three
prime untranslated polyadenylated tail
there are also accessory genes that are
inter spread within the structural genes
at the three prime end of the genome
these accessory proteins are almost
exclusively non-essential for
replication and tissue culture however
some have been shown to have important
roles and viral pathogen is's so here we
can see that the sequence of the
proteins of the novel coronavirus under
the accession number NC zero four five
five one two I'm going to post that in
chat for you to look at
virus on McClay Chur is a formal system
of names that's used to label viruses in
taxa the fact that there are names for
nearly all viruses when the species is
due to the historical perception that
viruses as causative agents of specific
diseases in specific hosts and to the
way that we visualize and catalog and
then classified newly discovered viruses
which increasingly includes viruses that
have not been linked to any known
disease or in their respective hosts the
World Health Organization which is an
agency of the United Nations coordinates
international public health activities
they're aimed at combating containing
and mitigating the consequences of
communicable diseases which include
major virus epidemics and it's
responsible for naming diseases that
caused by newly emerging human viruses
in doing so the World Health
Organization often takes a traditional
approach of linking names of specific
diseases to viruses and assessing virus
novelty by an apparent failure to detect
a causative agent using established
diagnostic assays apart from disease
geography and the organism from which a
given virus was isolated these also
dominate the nomenclature occasionally
Engraving connections that may be
accidental rather than typical or even
stagnant izing which can be avoided
so here we can see a virus species names
are often very similar to the name of
the founding member of respective
species and they're frequently confused
in the literature with names of
individual viruses of their species
you'll also notice that the species name
is italicized and it starts with a
capital letter and should not be spelled
with an abbreviated form hence the
species name severe acute respiratory
syndrome related coronavirus in contrast
this convention does not apply to virus
names so for instance there's severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
or SARS Cove as it's widely known so
essentially what this is saying is that
based on the type of virus is going to
be different types of naming schemes and
one of the main goals is to not
stigmatize certain groups based on the
number of available sequences we can
start asking a lot of different
questions because we already know about
the pathogenesis origin or replication
of a previous virus so for instance SARS
or MERS from the previous decade based
on comparative analysis of such
sequences we can derive how the current
genome is different as well as what
implications that might have on various
properties of its proteins a challenge
in analyzing so many genomes at once and
comparing them at multiple levels occurs
because we're doing this from nucleotide
amino acid and then organizational
properties and this challenge is that
the simple tools on NCBI do not allow
for such flexibility or processing power
so in our upcoming sessions we're going
to be leveraging server T - bio info
platform and we're gonna be running big
datasets and then comparing how the
various sequences differ at the genomic
level and we're gonna be studying
mutational fitness as well as virus
phylogeny so I see the mohit has posted
the link in the server and I encourage
you to take some
between now and our next session to go
on the server and utilize that resource
one such analysis that we can perform is
an advanced Bayesian phylogenetic
analysis such as Beast
it uses the birth-death process which is
most popular and evolutionary studies
and now there is called Yul and it's a
birth-death special case and here it's
expected that organisms are dying and
the population size is not constant in
the virus case the size is almost
constant and therefore coalescent
constant size might be a good option but
by running such an analysis will find
that the kovat 19 genome is closely
associated with SARS consistent with
previous reports SARS Cove in two
clusters with SARS coves and trees of
the species SARS related coronavirus and
the genus beta corona virus the distance
estimates between SARS Cova 2 and the
most closely related corona viruses are
going to vary amongst different studies
depending on the choice of measure and
this could be whether nucleotide or
amino acid or the genome region but
genomes don't only vary between their
species or well-defined strained there's
also a lot of variation that occurs
during the pandemic viral genomes
collected from various locations dates
hosts during a short time span can
reveal this trend if you would like to
see a pandemic in action you can visit a
website that I'll post in the chat it's
called neck strain or
and I'm actually going to hop out and
show you this website because I think
it's really cool so in here you can kind
of go in and zoom and see what's going
on for instance in the United Kingdom or
for instance what's going on in
Southeast Asia we can also look at
phylogeny and click on different
information to see what's going on with
that we can also switch the date range
and see that how that affects our
diagram as well as our map and so
anyways between now and next session I
encourage you to go on this website as
well and to play around with the various
parameters here and kind of see what
type of maps you can generate very cool
to find mutations with within a pandemic
such as SARS Co vid 2 we can select for
genomes specifically during this time
period and then analyze them for
variability at different levels but a
global sequence alignment is not the
full story for example in recent reviews
even a small number of genomes can
reveal specific changes that occur
between genomes that we need to be
looking for so here you can see the
relationship between recent and more
distant human and bat genomes with SARS
and novel coronavirus SARS COBIT to the
challenge that we'll turn to next is the
identification of specific ways these
genomes are different by looking at the
spike glycoproteins
chiral subunits that have specific
patterns that are important for its
function as well as the adaptation
between animal and human hosts
for us to start answering this question
we have to understand the data and how
to find it
and find meaningful biologically
interpreted data as well as the details
in the sequences so let's start by
clarifying some of the terminology that
we'll use an analysis fast a and fast q
are different types of files that you'll
be importing into the various pipelines
that we'll be running
there's also nucleotides which are
obviously the types of bases that are
involved in genomics
there's substitutions insertions and
deletions which are going to be various
types of polymorphisms that can occur
with nucleotides
there's amino acids which are going to
be the product they're going to be
linked as the product of translation
obviously there's mutations which are
variations that occur you're also going
to be reading about zoonotic
transmission and spillover which is what
happens between animals and humans and
then we have other terms such as cell
entry phylogenetic relationships and
then obviously DNA RNA and protein so
these are some terms that you can look
at as you're reading especially if
you're at a beginner level and wanting
to gain some more information genomes
are assembled from next-generation
sequencing which is typically done using
a process called shotgun sequencing this
process includes shattering the source
material which is going to be RNA or DNA
and then it's going to be sequencing of
short reads that have 32 300 base pairs
long
these sequences are going to be
assembled into a full genome by looking
at the consensus sequence in other words
if the sequence of reads all shows the
exact
letters they're gonna be considered as a
consensus if there's a disagreement
between these the majority is going to
win and as a result from a single
isolate we can get the full sequence of
a viral genome that's going to be most
abundant this process is fairly accurate
however it reduces the diversity of
potential present
variations of the virus in each sample
to a single sequence the more samples
like a sequence the higher our
confidence that the strain has a
consistent characteristic after these
sequences are found we can start looking
at the genomic characteristics such as
our genes or special coding sequences
that can be associated with a function
let's first speak about the sequence
itself we can talk about point mutations
and as well as the genetic code and how
amino acids are linked together to form
proteins when we compare sequences of
two genomes and a fast a file we will be
looking for variation typically we'll be
looking for a single point mutation or
what's called a single nucleotide
variation
these can be substitutions insertions or
deletions such changes have differential
biological significance because a single
nucleotide change can result in several
changes in the codon which is a set of
three nucleotides strung together that
are recorded in mRNA which will be
translated into protein remember that
proteins are our functional element
a gene that's typically recorded in DNA
form is going to be converted through
transcription into mRNA and then
translated into protein this machinery
is what's folded into the functional
product and here it's absolutely true
the structures indicated of a function
we're briefly going to go over the
various classes of building block amino
acids that comprise a functional peptide
so there's 20 standard amino acids that
occur in nature they can all be divided
up mostly between three classes these
are going to be polar charged polar
uncharged and nonpolar let's start with
the nonpolar amino acids the nonpolar
amino acids are generally going to be
found in the interior of peptides and
these are generally going to be
structural types of amino acids the
polar uncharged are typically going to
be at the cell or the protein surface
and these are polar but they do not
possess a charge generally an aqueous
solution they don't have any type of
acid-base properties the polar charged
however do possess either a negative
charge or a positive charge in these
types of amino acids generally occur in
the active site of enzymes or at some
functional aspect of the protein so
generally mutations that will change for
instance a glycine to availing won't
have a deleterious effect however if you
were to change an aspartic acid to say
for instance of valine that would cause
a very deleterious effect because this
is usually going to be found bound to
its counter ion which would be a
positively charged amino acid
so we can talk a little bit more about
cell structure as well as where these
amino acids might be found for example
the chemical the chemical properties of
amino acids explained how membrane
proteins function so here I'll talk
about lipid bilayers
as well as integral membrane proteins so
here we can see the outside of the cell
which is also called the extracellular
space and here we have different types
of insoluble molecules and then carrier
proteins that are involved in
transporting these either with or
against the concentration gradients on
the inside of the cell this is called a
cytoplasm or if it's referred to in
literature in reference to metabolism
called the cytosol and these different
types of molecules are brought in for
some biological purpose if the protein
is one that spans the membrane which is
generally around 70 angstroms long it's
called an integral membrane protein and
there's also types of proteins that are
called carrier proteins that are
involved in passive diffusion or
facilitated diffusion the bilayer has
two different parts to it one of which
is going to be a phospholipid head
these phospholipid heads are polar in
nature and so as we go through our amino
acids you'll see that generally a polar
or charged amino acid is going to be at
the surface of this protein right here
because the bilayer is also non polar in
nature on the inside here the types of
amino acids that would be present in
this protein in these regions would be
nonpolar in nature
so again these are the polar charged
amino acids these are hydrophilic
meaning that they want to bind to water
and they also possess a charge these are
the amino acids that you'll find that
are going to function in binding and
catalysis and so whenever you read about
the KO vid or SARS disease and the virus
you'll find that there are different
proteases that are involved with it
often times that the mechanism of that
action is going to be produced by way of
the different types of amino acids and
so as you go through you'll find that a
lot of these residues are gonna be very
important for that
another type of amino acid that we
talked about was uncharged polar amino
acids these are gonna be threonine
serine cysteine glutamine tyrosine and a
spar gene remember that these amino
acids are typically found on the outside
of the peptide and some of these also
function in binding in catalysis one
notable one would be the serine
proteases and then the ones that are
found on the interior peptides where
they minimize their contacts with water
are gonna be hydrophobic these types of
amino acids are generally structural and
for instance some of them produce kinks
and the protein structure for instance
prolene is what's called known as a
helix breaker other types of amino acids
function in other structural things such
as disulfide bonds which would be
between cysteine residues and as you go
through there's a lot to know about
amino acids but I think the general
take-home message from this should be
that they can be broken up into three
different classes and where they reside
in a protein is going to be dependent
upon their structure
and their proclivity to bind to water or
not proteins also have to be folded and
this is going to be done in a manner
that follows thermodynamics so the way
that proteins fold is going to be
governed by the fact that it's in an
aqueous solution and so with similar
proteins from different organisms the
structure tends to be more conserved
than the exact sequence of amino acids
mutations that occur are natural
variations and tend to be on the
exterior of proteins
many of our functional changes can be
studied from analysis of structure as
well as structure similarity proteins
are folded post-translationally and
create the 3d structure of a peptide
another concept you'll be reading about
our motifs which are simple combinations
of secondary structure elements which
are also referred to as super secondary
structural elements and so here we can
see a beta pleated sheet that occurs or
an alpha helix E's these are both called
secondary structure the actual sequence
of amino acids as they occur in a
peptide is what's referred to as the
primary structure and then how these
fold after translation defines the
tertiary structure one other term that
you might see is quaternary structure
and this is where subunits of do various
peptides are going to be interacting
with each other one example I can talk
to you about that has quaternary
structure would be hemoglobin which has
four different subunits linked to it
myoglobin is an example of a protein
that does not have a quaternary
structure because it all is only one of
these subunits
so when we study these variations
between viral genomes we have to
remember that the changes that we
observe at the sequence level will have
different impacts on protein structure
and function if we want to understand a
virus and how different in terms of
infectivity being the entry into a new
host or how effective it is at
replication we have to consider the
protein product there are several
different ways that we can study protein
function this can be based on the amino
acid sequence the theory be crystal
structure or high-throughput data that's
available from this protein interacting
with a host cell so here we can see a
peptide going from linear to a folded
form and then know that we can study
proteins based on amino acid sequence
the 3d structure or the data that we get
from gene expression let's look at
several project data sets where we can
see some of these methods that are
applied to real datasets that are
produced from these outbreaks let's talk
about where it all began in the full
program we're gonna be looking at a
dataset where the first novel
coronavirus genome was detected and
assembled the project is titled
the detection of viral genomes from
hyuna human and bat metagenomic
sequencing here the identification and
characterization of the new corona virus
occurs which has caused an epidemic of
acute respiratory syndrome in humans
from Wuhan China this epidemic started
on December 12 2019 and at the time it
caused 2794 laboratory confirmed
infections including 80 deaths by 20 by
the 26th of January full genome
sequences were obtained from five
patients at the early stages of the
outbreak the sequences were almost
identical and shared seventy nine point
six C
identity two stars cope furthermore it
was shown that 2019 n Cove is 96%
identical to the whole genome level that
of the bat coronavirus pairwise protein
sequence analysis of seven conserved non
structural protein domains show that the
virus belongs to the species of s o
Soros Cove in addition to thousand teen
and Co virus was isolated from the
bronchial alveolar lavage fluid of a
critically ill patient that could be
neutralized by sera from several
different patients notably the authors
confirmed that 2019 and Cove uses the
same sell entry receptor which is called
a stew and that's short for angiotensin
converting enzyme to let me post a link
to the paper here for you to take a look
at between now and next session where
we're going to talk about proteins
so here we have the spiked glycoprotein
and it's genome has been sequenced and
that genomic information was promptly
released despite a high similarity with
the genome sequence of SARS Cove and the
SARS light coves we identified a
peculiar fear in like cleavage site in
the spy protein of the 2019 encode which
lacks and the other SARS lack Co bits so
there are possible functional
consequences of this cleavage site in
the viral cycle as well as the
pathogenesis pathogenicity and its
potential implication in the development
of antivirals another project is the
viral protein function the title for
that is the release of severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus
nuclear import which blocks and enhances
host transcription in human lung cells
the purpose of the experiment was to
compare transcriptomics of to be four
cells which are clonal derivatives of
kallu 3 cells that were infected with
either icy soros cove or the icy SARS
delta or six mutant of that virus they
had a pretty unique experimental design
the cao lu 3 cells were infected with
either icy soros cove or the icy SARS
delta or six newton the sample cells
were collected at various intervals in
the post affection phase and then each
infected sample was done in triplicate
and so triplicates are defined as three
different wells which are plated at the
same time using the same cell stock for
all replicates there are triplet time
matched marks for each time point from
the cell stock as the rest of the
samples and then the culture medium
which is the same as what the virus
stock is in was used for the mock
infections I'll also post that link in
the chat for you for you to peruse at
your convenience
so on Friday we're going to be
discussing protein changes as well as
viral entry and we're going to talk a
little bit more about coronavirus
biology specifically the entrance of the
virus into the cell and how this virus
replicates we're also going to be
talking about the analysis of viral
proteins and then mapping nucleotide
sequences on protein structures that
interact with human proteins so I look
forward to seeing you on Friday and we
can have that discussion then I have one
more thing to talk to you about today
and it is our agenda or gene lab which
is an option that you have for
purchasing a research license on the T
bio info research platform it includes
five terabytes of storage and three
hours of support with one of our
specialists I'll also post that link in
the chat for you to take a look at and I
have to mention that in the month of
April we're going to be offering a 50%
discount for research licenses and
educational licenses due to the corona
virus outbreak so please take advantage
of that and I look forward to seeing you
on Friday I hope that you all have a
wonderful week
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
you